thank you
dear Leslie Locker
magnificent
distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen
very warm welcome to all the young faces
and students I see here and the teachers
of this University
it is an enormous privilege
to join you here in the breathtaking
city of Venice I have the pleasure to be
here with my commissioner Elisa Ferreira
and I feel very honored
to be here at the biennale one of the
most important events for Architects and
designers
it is the first time
that the European Union takes part in
the biennale of architecture
with a dedicated event
it's always also my first time here in
the beautiful city of Venice
and I must say I'm absolutely stunned
and I think you know this feeling the
first time when you came here it's
amazing when you come to the venue by
boat
at that time I started to understand
what Montesquieu meant when he had said
you may have seen many cities in the
world almost all cities in the world
but when you see Venice
you will be surprised
and he said right indeed Venice is a
World's Marvel
here in Venice generations of Architects
have created a unique balance balance
between man-made Beauty
and natural beauty
so I think there could be no better
place to have the biennale and the new
European avao house here in Venice
and I'm very glad that
um you have the title of this year's
biennial at the laboratory of the future
because the new European Bauhaus is
indeed just that
it is a laboratory of the future
it has already been said that this
month's Italy has once again
suffered from the devastating impact of
climate change
I was yesterday
Romania
I've seen the vast amount of land that
is covered with water
I've seen the mudslides the scars in the
landscape
countless cars in the landscape
I've seen these incredible amounts of
much and when I walked through the
streets that I've filled with were
filled with mud of course the first
impression is you're struck by the
devastating damage this natural force
can develop
but I must tell you I was all so struck
by the amazing reaction of the people
in Emilia romagna
they were tirelessly
to clean not only their own houses but
an enormous solidarity to help their
neighbors
we've seen these so-called angels in the
mud countless volunteers from all over
Italy anieline alfango
we've seen The Rescuers coming from
France from Belgium from Slovenia and
Slovakia
and it was very good that I could at
that moment
tell the people of Familia romagna
you're not alone
Europe is by your side
you know
The Motto tin bottle by Convoy
and it's also important not only to be
here at the moment being
but of course to support the region also
when it's about reconstruction
and reconstruction is finding the
balance again between nature and the
built environment
our recovery plan Next Generation EU
which is a far-reaching plan and not for
the actual damage right now
has and that's good around 6 billion
euros for Italy to reduce the risk for
example of floods of mudslides for
instance we will restore the bed of the
river pot
removing concrete we will reactivate
lateral branches we will bring nature
basically back to the river
because I'm deeply convinced we must
make nature our Ally otherwise we'll
never manage to fight really climate
change
and the Damage damages that humans have
done to climate are of course also very
much visible when you're here in Venice
I was told that by the end of the
century the water level in Venice could
rise from a minimum of at least 30
centimeters to a maximum of another
meter
we cannot avert the worst case scenario
but we can do everything
to fight climate change and therefore
reduce the impact and reduce the damage
that is being done and they are the most
important part is that's why we're here
that we work hard on cutting emissions
through the way we build and we heat our
homes so that we slow down the effects
of climate change and of course by this
also slow down the rise of the sea level
and we know that we can do it
we can do it with better use of energy
and water
we can use natural materials like for
example Timber
we can use more Renovations of existing
buildings
so to preserve our planet
and the beauty of our planet we must
urgently transform the way we build and
we heat our homes and this is
essentially what the new European
Bauhaus is all about
there's another connection
between Venice and the new European
Bauhaus
the Venetian Republic was home to you
know him all Andrea Palladio
a famous Master of the Renaissance
and one of the most influential
architects of all times
his legacy lies not only in the
beautiful Villas he left behind and in
changing venice's Skyline
but also in his work on the theory
of architecture
he rediscovered
the ancient Latin ideas
the idea is that the perfect building
must be durable
and at the same time beautiful
and useful
and for centuries Architects have been
inspired by this Triad durability Beauty
utility
and these three principles are basically
also the three principles of the new
European Bauhaus
durability and our understanding is
sustainability
paladio believe that a building had to
stand the test of time
and today we know that the ultimate test
of time is whether we can preserve our
planet for future Generations so
buildings will only stand the test of
time
if they are built sustainably
the second element
principle
is beauty
rationally from our mind we understand
that climate action is necessary
but Sustainable Building should also go
to the heart it should touch you
and with the new European vowels we want
to show that the necessary
can also be beautiful
we must make Beauty our Ally to fight
climate change
and the third element the third
principle we have added a strong social
Dimension to palladio's idea of utility
Beauty and sustainability must be of
course affordable they must be
affordable for everybody
therefore the third principle of the new
European Bauhaus is inclusivity
everybody should be taken along nobody
should be left behind
Beauty
and sustainability must be for everyone
thus inclusive
it's been almost three years now since
we presented these three principles of
the new European battle house
and the enthusiasm that we have
encountered so far
has been overwhelming
over 600 organizations have joined us as
partners and we're death in three years
only
with the local initiatives they have
reached millions of European citizens
and the principles of the new European
Bauhaus have also inspired some
independent initiatives for instance
several organizations in the wood
industry have launched wood for Bauhaus
or the fashion and textile organizations
have created a European Alliance
for a more sustainable future for the
fashion industry following the
principles of the new European Bauhaus
the new European Bauhaus has even
reached beyond the borders of the
European Union
the University of Harvard
has created a course about the new
European Bauhaus
and I must say I am very glad
that we work particularly very strongly
together with our friends in Ukraine
I must say very clearly one day
after Russia's atrocious War we will
rebuild this beautiful country of
Ukraine
the brave people of Ukraine deserve our
full support for this reconstruction
and we have discussed over the last
months with our Ukrainian friends that
when rebuilding the country From the
Ashes of the war it should happen in a
sustainable way so the new European
Bauhaus is showing the way while we are
training Ukrainian municipalities
Architects Engineers urban planners from
the European Union and from Ukraine are
sharing their expertise on how to
rebuild Ukraine sustainably I was very
glad to hear from the mayor this morning
that the port of Venice is also twinning
with the port of Odessa
to bring also the knowledge the
expertise and immediately the
sustainable way to rebuild the port of
Odessa
what means sustainable rebuilding for
example that we take the debris from the
destruction of war and recycle them for
the destroyed from the destroyed
buildings for rebuilding new ones so
with the support of the European Union
as the young European Bauhaus community
I am deeply convinced that Ukraine can
be rebuilt not just as it was
but as the young people of Ukraine wants
it to be more sustainable
more inclusive
even more beautiful
this is a goal I think we all share that
Ukraine will overcome this war and
Ukraine will rise again
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen Italy
has responded with extraordinary
enthusiasm to the new European Bauhaus
over 100 partners and Friends of the new
European Bauhaus are Italians
including the University of course that
is hosting us today
in these beautiful premises and the
Venice Urban lab
and there are three stories
from the new European Bauhaus community
in Venice and in Italy's Northeast
that have really impressed me and I want
to share these stories with you it's a
story from the sea
it's a story from the mountains
and it's a story from the frontier
so let me guide you through these three
stories and landscapes
before I conclude with what lies ahead
of us
the first story is from right here in
Venice
from two Waterfront neighborhoods called
San basilio and Santa Marta
these two neighborhoods you know it
better than me used to be the home to
fishermen's and their families
in the summer nights fishermen and
Fisher women would gather on the beach
they would roast their fish
they would chat through the night they
would attract people from all over
Venice they would celebrate the night
and the day
but then factories and warehouses
conquered the space
a conquered the space
only to be abandoned during the last
century and that's how you know these
regions
today life is coming back
to this community
the University
together with kafaskari
the mayor
and the Port Authorities
have joined a project called Bauhaus of
the Seas sales
it is one of the first six demonstrator
projects of the new European Bauhaus and
indeed San basilio in Santa Marta are
basically rejuvenated you the ones who
are working here together on the project
are creating new student residencies
you're creating new economic activities
and focus on sustainable Fishery
you're creating new public spaces to
reconnect the two neighborhoods with the
Waterfront
so with the Bauhaus of the Seas
you can basically restore the natural
bond between this beautiful city and the
sea
now let me take you away from the Lagoon
for a moment
and up to the mountains the mountain
that you can see I was told on clear
days from Venice
role
a group of local associations together
with the province and the University of
Boston
have created a new European Bauhaus lab
project called
Bauhaus of the mountains
they are convening people from different
backgrounds Architects Farmers
sculptures scientists designers even DJs
and they are working together on new
ideas for the built environment in the
Alps
they are setting up art exhibits on
mountaintops
they are planning affordable and
sustainable homes for young
professionals
it is a bottom-up experience that is
bringing the Bauhaus Spirit up to the
mountains
and finally after the scene
and the mountains comes the frontier
I'm not only talking about the frontier
between countries
but also
between
human civilization and nature
the third story comes from a small
village called topolo it's somewhere
lost in the woods between the board of
Italy and Slovenia
and there was a small village and this
Village was almost entirely abandoned
but some young artists and Architects
started to move in again and they
decided
to preserve the ancient beauty of the
place
to avoid to build new structures
instead they turned every empty building
into across the village into some shared
spaces where they can work together they
can eat together they can create art
together you name it
they have turned the whole village into
one common home
and for this
they have won the new European Bauhaus
Prize last year rightly so
[Applause]
thank you
ladies and gentlemen as you can see
Italy is an important driver of the new
European Bauhaus and an endless source
of inspiration and Innovation for our
movement
today I would like to say thank you for
that
these projects show not only the
diversity the beauty of the new European
Bauhaus
but also the impact that the initiative
that is only three years ongoing now has
gotten
today the new European Bauhaus Community
has grown so much that you
have asked us
to establish local chapters of the new
European Bauhaus
I know that venice's local chapter is
meeting for the first time on the
occasion
of the biennale
other local chapters are being set up
all across the European Union for
example in Sweden in Spain in Germany in
Latvia you name it
and there are many familiar faces here
in the audience that are working on that
tirelessly so I hope
you can feel the same joy as I do that
the new European Bauhaus idea is finally
up and running and that's good I'm glad
about it
for us in the European Institute and
this is
how to keep supporting you
and your impressive mobilization
one important tool is the new European
Bauhaus Academy
First Academy Pioneer hubs are being
established as we speak
the academy will train construction
professionals
they have a responsibility
not only towards the small piece of land
they are working on but towards the
whole world and he's so right end of
quote this is the spirit of the new
European Bauhaus thank you for listening
and Long Live Europe thank you
[Applause]
[Music]